في اخي تطورات المتعلقه بالحرب الدائره
بين المكونين العسكريين في السودان قال
الجيش السوداني في بيان رسمي انما حصل كان
محاوله الاستيلاء على الحكم بقوه
المتمردين واكد البيان ان محاوله
المتمردين او اعوانهم من عملاء الداخل
والخارج في التسويق لمشروعهم القائم على
تزييف الحقائق قد فشلت واشار بيان الجيش
الا ان المعركه وحدت الشعب وقواته المسلحه
وزادت بل وقواته المسلحه وزادت من حرص
ابناء الوطن على اهميه بقاء قواته المسلحه
كما اكد البيان على العمل على تهيئه
الظروف المناسبه لكل اجهزه الدوله من
استئناف عملها وعوده الحياه لطبيعتها
باسرع وقت ممكن
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت من جانبها الجيش
السوداني بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه عبر
مهاجمه مراكزها وعدد من الاحياء السكنيه
في الخرطوم بواسطه الطيران والمدفعيه هذا
وجددت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها
التزامها الكامل بالهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه لفتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين لقضاء
احتياجاتهم ولتسهيل عمليات الاجلاء
اجت الطيران
نقابه اطباء السوداني في تقييدها اليومي
افادت بارتفاع ضحايا الاشتباكات في البلاد
الى 411 قتيلا من المدنيين واصابه 2023
اخرين واوضحت النقابه في بيان ان الاقتتال
الاخير في مدينه الجنينه اوقعت ساعه 89
قتيلا مشيره الى انه لا يوجد حصر دقيق
لعدد الاصابات واضافت النقابه ان جميع
المستشفيات في المدينه خارج الخدمه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات